是我可以说是老公吧，
在一起大概已经8年了，
然后我们俩是一起创业6年了，
我后在大概前一个月吧，
就是我们在工作上一直就是负责的领域不太一样，
他负责售前售后，
我大概就负责技术啊，
员工管理啊，
采购啊，
就是两个人是相辅相成的，
就是我们是来到了我的家乡创业，
我们俩是是距离很远，
他是来到了我的家乡，
就是他是一个工作狂吧，
每天会花很多很多时间在工作上面，
然后也比较不愿意沟通，
但是整体的方向是就是这个生意是越做越好，
是越来越好的，
但是我们就一直会有争执，
然后我又觉得他不沟通了，
我们现在有个孩子，
她是一岁三个月，
这样后大概在我怀孕以后，
他就呃有出现过几次，
就是说要搬出去，
就觉得我老是逼他，
就觉得我老是指责他，
觉得他工作回来又后很辛苦了，
然后我还就是叨叨他呀，
指责他这样子，
因为他实在是太工作狂了，
就是每天都干到个十一二点，
然后回到家之后就熬夜熬到个三四点，
然后长期长期是这样的，
365天都不带休息的那种，
然后我有了孩子以后，
就是他对我和孩子的陪伴也非常非常的，
大概一个月之前他就搬出去。
就感觉说我一直逼他，
然后他搬出去的意思就是说大家继续一起共同工作，
然后赚的钱呢，
就呃负责家里的开销，
然后剩下的利润大家就分，
这样子，
他想要这样子，
其实这个工作嘛，
就是这个生意，
就是属于说其实没了谁他都是不行的，
特别是如果没了我的话，
其实现在已经是很乱的了，
已经是员工也提出要离职啊什么的，
就是这个店里的员工是我一直在维系的，
他就是负责一个售前售后这样子，
然后现在店里已经非常非常的乱，
然后我们也去拉锯离什么的，
然后就是他在搬出去，
他跟他父母关系是很疏远的哈，
然后他在搬出去之前，
他给他妈妈打了个电话，
就说哎呀，
她很痛苦，
她很难受，
所以她肯定是要搬出去了，
叫她妈过来，
然后她妈妈就过来了嘛，
就是相当于他们两个就一起在外面住着，
然后我婆婆这个人就是她也不太爱搭理我，
我婆婆以前说过话就是感觉就是跟我们生活不来嘛，
然后就是大家就远离就好了哈，
我婆婆是这个意见，
然后就我们是结婚啊，
我们是没有领证的，
其实当时是基于各种考虑这政策啊，
想以后二套什么的也是，
他太就是所有关注力都在那个工作里面，
然后他每天就是呃，
上班健身回家，
然后他就是一个很偏执的人，
他吃东西食物什么的就是。
做成7份，
一周每天都吃这样的食物，
然后现在大概情况就这样拉锯到现在就是不知道怎么办，
我是选择了我断臂，
我说我什么都不要了，
因为我受不了这样子的状态，
但我内心肯定是有不甘的，
包括我的那个团队是非趁好的一个团队，
为我那个团队很多人跟我也干了很好几年，
我问你啊，
姑娘啊，
我来问你啊，
现在你和你的这个孩子他爸，
你们两个人现在的财产分布状况是什么样的，
我举个例子啊，
说你们打拼这些年总共挣了1000万，
好，
这一千万百分之多少在你的名下，
百分之多少在他的名下，
我们这些年挣的钱的话，
都是就是用于生活开销，
就用于了啊，
然后剩下的就是余额的话，
我们是已经对半开了，
已经开掉了，
然后这些他是物欲很低的一个人，
就是可以说这些年赚的钱，
如果说是花掉了的话，
大部分也是花在了我这里啊，
就是在经济上可以这么理解，
在经济上你们两个人相互不亏待，
然后他挣的钱也大部分花到了你的身上，
这么理解不能说他赚的钱，
这个创业的技术和第一步要的资源都是我们这边去给他提供了，
那创业初期主要是你这边提供的技术和资源，
但是你也是人家。
工作很尽心尽力的，
每天加班到十一二点，
这个工作的过程当中，
这几年的过程中，
我们抽离出来，
不要把自己当成是女朋友，
我们就把自己当成一个投资客，
我们是一个投资方，
我们来看待这八年的创业过程当中，
他的贡献很大的就是其实我们现在这个店的模式，
虽然说是干的很红红火火哈，
但是这模式出现一点问题是要到了一个改革的时候，
就无论我在不在，
咱俩有没有这个事情，
我们都是需要改革的，
因为方向出现了一点问题，
就是他很偏执嘛，
一直不愿意沟通，
他只盯着一个点去干嘛，
但是就是你做生意是要配合的嘛，
那团队拉不起啊，
太苦了呀，
然后你说要扩大什么的，
他也完全是因为他太沉浸于那个方向了，
就是完全不沟通，
沟通不了，
你没有正面回答我的问题，
我的问题就是我们不管你当女朋友，
我们抽离出来，
就说你是一个投资方，
你来看待这个男人，
他在这个公司干了8年的，
这个过程当中，
他的贡献大不大，
他的贡献很大，
也就是说人家是一心扑在工作上，
我们可以去质疑他的，
比如说格局、
眼界，
呃，
方向，
但是他实际上还是一心扑在这个公司的工作。
讲的他也没有二心对吧，
没有私心，
他也没有说呢，
我想我一方面我铺在这家公司，
另一方面我自己捞点资源，
我再赚点别的钱，
没有这么干吗？
嗯，
想问我的问题是说你们这段关系应该呃怎么走下去，
你可能更倾向于要跟他分开，
是这意思不？
我就觉得既然咱家感情上已经分开了，
工作是不可能继续一起做，
因为大家如果说感情上分开了，
就是他也会有他的新生活，
我也会有我的新生活，
这样子大家在拉在一起的话，
就是后面就是无限的痛苦，
他在两年前是有出过一次，
反正就是各种原因之下，
事业啊，
家庭方面我还是原谅了他，
哦，
那你要这么说的话，
你们都已经分好了，
现在问题的症结是这个事业，
这个事儿上应该怎么搞的话，
谁有这个本事把这一摊接过来谁搞，
你也不要觉得说哎呀对吧，
我觉得挺受伤的，
或者说我觉得哎呀就不想跟他好了，
我就把这一摊事业我就扔给他吧，
不要这么想，
问题就这事业在谁手上，
能经营的好，
在谁手上，
呃，
大不了就是说，
比如说这个公司都归你的情况下，
你给他一点经济上的补偿，
给多少钱合适是吧，
不要觉得因为我跟你要分手了，
所以我就什么都不要了，
我这公司我就甩给你了，
你甩。
他他不一定能经营好嘛，
就像你说的，
技术是你，
资源是你，
他是售前和售后，
他售前和售后这事儿是吧，
可是意见性是比较强嘛，
说这个生意嘛，
他价值多少，
他也没有价值多少，
他就是老是给我提出一个很高的金额，
就说那他就拿了这个金额以后，
他就走了，
但是他也是反反复复也是没有确认哈，
一会这样一会那样，
他让我拿出这么高的一个金额给他，
那这个生意接下来还能不能赚回来，
这个钱我是确认不了，
就是股权在谁手上，
财务在谁手上，
都在他手上，
就是这些年经营就是赚的钱啊什么的都是在他手上的，
就是我是对他极其的信任，
然后钱都在他手上，
那我们反过来呢，
让他给我一笔钱，
我退出呢，
那他肯定不愿意，
他就想像现在一样，
他在外面生活，
然后我继续跟他去做这个店，
然后赚了钱大家分，
他就想这样子，
那我们谈的这个利益大概是多大的利益呢？
他要你给多少钱，
他要我给他150，
你们一年的利润大概是多少钱，
我们现在就是说这个一整年的利润到不了，
如果事情很平稳，
前景也比较好，
我感觉啊，
你接下来对吧，
给砍砍价，
就是给他个100也是比较划算的，
因为你一年就挣回来了，
连生意这个东西谁也不好保证嘛，
而且这我手上也没有这个钱，
我还要去借这笔钱给他，
我就觉得对我未来的压力也太大了。
与其给他150，
要不就是我重新来过还是怎么办，
我会有这样子的想法，
你重新来过，
你你也吃起来这一摊儿是不是啊，
可以，
但是只是说我就小一点，
会小一点，
就是这样，
那就是让他给你一部分的分期，
给呗，
不会给我，
因为他就是想要这样，
那你能把这些骨干带走吗？
我把这些骨干带走问题，
我的摊子也还没支起来，
我也不可能去给人家承诺什么东西，
你说是吧，
我把他们带走，
我的经压力也会很呆，
因为我那盘子我都资源都还没有，
没有积累，
我突然把人家带走，
我带着大家，
就是大家抱在一起干什么呢？
就是我都还没把自己支棱起来，
就你这个事儿，
现在你是被动的状态，
原因是什么？
因为公司的股权财务都在男方的手里，
然后呢，
你朋友没有结婚证，
男方不管干什么，
其实说白了，
现在从法律上来说都是他的个人财产，
就是当感情不存在了的时候，
你也没有任何可以牵制他的东西了。
唯一可能有一点，
如果他对孩子有感情的话，
他可能舍不得孩子，
对孩子很冷漠，
如果是这种情况的话啊，
有证据能证明你们在同居的过程当中，
是在一起投资这个公司，
一起经营这家公司的话，
那就该怎么分怎么分，
该打官司打官司呗，
该分钱分钱呗，
就如果你能够证明你们比如说有很多聊天记录。
啊，
能够证明你们是共同投资了，
共同经营了这个企业，
可打官司啊，
我确实这是该司，
你从现在开始，
你就要开始套他的话了，
假设我我的目的是要分钱，
我的目的是要分到我该拿到的，
那么我现在的所有的作为我都是要去啊，
构建证据，
注意啊，
这里不是伪造，
这里就是属于把证据给构建出来，
我跟他在聊天的时候啊，
聊天的那个方向就一定是啊，
当初我们俩我投了多少钱，
我们一起创办的这个企业，
说是登记在你的名下，
实际上是我们共同来经营这个企业，
就郑大的啊，
就一系列的套路都得上，
你到时候打官司的时候才有证据可以拿出来，
哎，
其实我不想走到那，
我大不了就给他拖死了，
只是我心态上，
我现在需要沉得住气，
就是我每一天一天的日子其实还蛮难过的，
因为我本来也是一直在工作中，
我现在突然就是闲下来了，
我不会去跟他打官司什么的，
因为我觉得我们曾经都相爱过，
都付出过，
说实话，
就像公屏上说的，
也不是说有多大笔以钱，
只是我们都在这里面投入了很多感情和很多精力在里面，
可能也边走边看啊，
就他跟妈妈住一段时间了之后，
我说句难听点的话，
他要找不到跟你能力相当，
比你能力还强。
你更优秀的女的，
她可能也就回头了呢，
你就这样再多聊两句，
就如果我最终的目的不是去跟她分钱，
可能还是边走边看的话，
那我可以换个思路，
换个思路是什么呢？
她现在跟他妈妈出去住，
可能就是因为我老说他晚上对吧，
怎么还不睡呀，
这么晚了对吧，
老管他这些事儿，
那换个思路就是说，
如果我不管你，
当我对你没有那么深的爱，
没有那么深的关心，
我不在乎你的身体，
我不在乎你早死的时候，
我就不管你，
我给你轻松，
我给你愉悦，
我给你自由，
还能接着过，
不就是他继续赚钱，
我继续能分钱的关系吗？
对吧？
我这么讲你能接受吗？
我只要把我的这个态度调整好了，
不就是你继续拼命赚钱，
你每天熬到11点，
你对吧？
去应酬，
你去找资源，
你去找售后，
你去管起业务分钱呗，
就是这种关系吗？
你当你有一天你这么想明白了之后，
这事儿关系就能调解，
哎，
你不要把他当成你的爱人，
不要把他当成你关心的人，
不要当把他当成孩子的爸爸，
你希望他活的长，
你天天关心他啊，
不要熬夜啊，
你就把他当成啊合伙人，
他愿意工作狂，
他就个工作狂，
你就换这个思路了之后你会发现啊，
豁然开朗，
他的工作狂就这一瞬间就变成了。
无比好的一个优点。